AJA HAMMERLY:
Today I'll show you
how to get alerts on
changes to your system.
I would like to get an email
any time someone creates a VM
instance in my project.
In StackDriver logging, select
GCE VM Instance, and then
select Activity.
Now you can see all the audit
logs on my GCE resources.
If I expand this one, I
see that the method name
is compute instances insert,
which is a VM create.
So I'm going to show
matching entries,
just to see my create logs.
In order to get an alert,
I need to create a metric.
I name my metric.
And then I click Create Metric.
Now I go to Stackdriver
monitoring and click
Create An Alert Policy.
I add a condition using
a metric threshold.
And my resource
type, in this case,
is going to be log metrics.
I can select my user-defined
metric here, set a threshold,
and then save the condition.
I said I wanted to
be notified, so I'm
going to set up an
email notification.
I could also use SMS,
a web hook or the app,
or any of the other
notification methods
available in
StackDriver monitoring.
I'm going to name my policy.
And then I'll save the policy.
Now if someone creates a VM
instance, I will get an email.